all right so this is evicted and tree
Johnson was back that was cool she had
no lights or anything but like where she
come from it there she was but okay so
that happened um and this has a
character the the vampire queen named
wasn't because with an M Marceline and
the Marceline and I think the first girl
character not a princess in this
actually I actually thought that might
be the running joke that every girl was
gonna be a princess like cuz that's just
how he I just had this assumption that
the whole world is like how he would
ever after the apocalypse whatever like
he just made up his fantasy world like
Sora house Oh adventure fun and video
games that's just sort of how he saw a
girl like at that age it's like that was
just his perception but yeah so um they
live that they got their house there uh
Finn and Jake and I say good
Marceline Marceline Mark said Marceline
comes in and says that pretty much my
house kicks him out they go looking for
another place they find a cave she takes
that - cuz she apparently claimed that
and they have a fight and she's like hey
that fight was fun take your old plays
back and oh no yeah and there's worms
little words and the King worm
hypnotizes them to give hugs like that
never touch me again and that is the
episode what is the show okay so
destroying old people and worms I'm
noticing a lot of worms in this show
like you know us I like when he gets
bundled up in the in the sleeping bag he
looks like a worm there's always worms
crawling I'm saying even in that the
heart episode with the Bubblegum
character which she was tied up she
looks like a worm like everything looks
like a worm
if this snail it's like a worm with a
shell I it's I don't get what the
obsession is with worms honestly I don't
know okay okay that's a great up thing
so um but yeah good uh Marceline
characters fine I mean she just seems
sort of like a laid-back rocker chick
just sort of does whatever
she wants and serve like I don't want
like a gap version of Finn but sort of
like and it may be a more aggressive
version of fan like she will kick people
out just as her do whatever she wants
where Finn will sort of like what to
help but do it in whatever way she wants
yeah so I mean I was a funkier now that
was pretty cool um I actually like for a
split second did sort of like oh oh no
when she bit Jake I mean I knew he's
gonna be okay obviously but the same
time I was her like oh wow they can't
get out of that one I love that reason
just say I put all my guts and the other
thing I can think of is that the again
just one of the nice things about what
kind of nice characters they are is that
whenever they were traveling like I
guess cuz Jake can change in anything
like he's constantly covering the rain
for Finn and like when he's cold and
like was that his ear to like use as a
fly against that like just that's nice I
mean it's like for all the really weird
extreme stuff in this show like it's
still really nice it's really like just
Pleasant and everybody's like really
close and friendly it I don't know it's
it's it's cool it's very upbeat which I
really like having his home stolen twice
and Finn getting all upset you know Jake
just says no home is where your heart is
and you know we're together and he's
like you know what you're right screw
this that's fine you can steal our
second home I'm with Jake and it's only
when she says well then I'm gonna take
Jake Jake is now mine that he really has
nice underneath fights back yeah it's
really nice to see that home is a great
thing but friendships more powerful than
that yeah I mean I mean the place is
exactly that a place as long as you have
what's really important around you yeah
you know good friends not things that's
the important yeah
lesson for the day this episode also
introduces fan favorite Marceline
mmm-hmm Marceline is one of those that
you'll see a lot of cosplayers as her
and she's definitely a fun character
especially as time goes along you know I
haven't I'd gone to a lot of cons I
haven't noticed but all honesty a lot of
that might be that the cosplay is sort
of very
it looks very basic I mean it's like
just sort of like a tank top jeans and
like maybe some vampire teeth that's
about it so so so maybe that's it saying
that could be just a normal condo or
honestly now I'm gonna keep an eye out
for it when cuz the other ones like
bubble gum and femen's definied say it's
like you can tell it's like oh yeah but
no yeah no that's actually one of the
characters I was hoping like you see on
the opening credits oh that's sue me
yeah she's coming back but as well as
like nothing else fun I wouldn't mind
seeing that character come back likely
but tree trunks also when I was happy to
see again I was on TV she had no libel
where'd she come from
Weymouth actually that's the thing um a
lot of people like to tear apart shows
for continuity errors and whatnot and I
know I've heard people talk about it
that oh this show is we really supposed
to be put out before this one and all
that stuff like timeline wise I have no
idea any of that but you know this is
technically a continuity error okay
where yeah I don't know why tree trunks
is there if that's even tree trunks I
mean it looks like she's the only
Ellsbury's reach oh god they know like
got a close-up of her - yeah that's
pretty good tree trunks but yeah that's
definitely a continuity she was in the
credits even though she had no lines it
actually said so and so as tree trunks I
didn't see that ya know it was in there
I did see that even if she doesn't say
anything so it's really weird maybe it's
just to piss off the continuity people
even more that's possible no I did hear
one or two things like because I guess
like the first episode I saw I saw a lot
of people say like no technically that
wasn't the first episode there was like
a pilot that explained a little bit more
or something like that um and I was
hearing it too like some episodes are
shown not in the order that like in
Caribbeans supposed to be like the first
episode after the pilot yeah that's your
one I heard and I just go off of how
like just looking online or the DVD it
says this is the order that there and
that's kind of how I go and if people
want a bitch and moan about continuity
and all that stuff I just say it's a
kids show yeah I mean it it seems like
it's pretty you know like it's totally
drenched in random does any yeah I mean
it's I'll know if it gets more into like
a cohesive story or whatever bed so yeah
as of now it's like random fun goofy a
you know kind of stuff so I don't think
it's a thing to get like that obsessed
oh it does get to a cohesive story but
there's always episodes in there that
are kind of goofy and fun like another
continuity error if you really want to
look at it was from my two favorite
people where Finn has hands and he's got
five fingers when normally yes justice
four fingers oh really it's a small
little continuity error that you know
people can gripe about and you're
welcome let's go
I love the show but cotton newer dares
continuity errors happen in everything
so yeah you know just a kids show and
the one thing I asked about before wrap
up here is that I don't really look at
the title cards and some of them like
really make sense you know like some of
them are like oh yeah that's like what
the episode was about but then others
like you know I was just thinking back
to the the boom boom mountain one like
the title card is just them looking at a
duck I'm like what am I like and I know
I'm sure that's like whatever one of the
ducks that they use to whatever type in
the hands and but it's like why that and
like I guess I'm wondering do you know
at all is there anything to the title
cards where it's like some really
connect or some really random and like
even just the layout of it sort of
looking like an old comic book you know
it does do they ever serve go more into
that or is it just you don't really know
you don't you never really know I mean
you're right some of the title cards are
like dead on you know exactly I'm kind
of what's going on or plays into it but
like yeah with that one not good
maybe it is one of the ducks you know
maybe that's all it was I don't know
unless I go again okay yeah so let me
make a gif of that just I'm going rant
where yeah you know there's gonna be a
couple now I face play they're gonna be
like you know here's five of those gifts
so thanks a lot so yeah try to any other
I mean I like the Marx Marceline
Marceline my Marceline character I like
the episode I like the little fight they
had the end I like that weird song in
the middle that I think is sung by the
Creator cuz I don't you did the opening
song it sounds a lot like yeah it does
sound like Pendleton
but I could be completely wrong to be
honest so one of those fans that like
sits there and looks up credits and I
just enjoy the damage unless it's tree
trunks I I looked that up but yeah so no
good good episode anything else you get
no I'm good
okay cool so we'll see you next
adventure time my glass is